the best way to understand permutations
and combinations is by solving as many
examples as possible in this example we
have been asked to arrange the letters
of the word Rock in how many different
ways can the letters of the word Rock be
arranged we have one word and we need to
rearrange the letters to form different
arrangements as Rock has four letters
let's make four slots what exactly are
we asked for in how many ways can the
letters be arranged we can form
arrangements like Oh our KC or CR o K or
K o RC and so on how many such
arrangements can we form if you have
gone through our previous sessions you
would immediately realize that this
problem is no different it's like we
have been given four different digits
and asked for the number of four digit
numbers that can be formed do we have
any condition here nope we have simply
been asked for the number of possible
ways in which these letters can be
rearranged so we can start from anywhere
say we start with the first slot in how
many ways can the first slot be occupied
the word Rock has four letters so the
first slot can be filled with any of
these four letters four ways now having
filled the first slot in how many ways
can the second slot be filled one of the
letters has been used in the first slot
three remain the second slot can be
filled in three ways if we have used an
O in the first slot then we can use any
one from our C and K for the second slot
if we use a C in the first slot then
anyone from our oh and K can be used in
a second
now having filled the first and the
second slot with one letter each in how
many ways can the third slot be filled
two ways as just two letters would
remain and the fourth slot can be filled
with just one way as three letters have
already been used up four ways in which
we can fill the first slot
three ways in which the second slot can
be filled two ways in which the third
slot can be filled and after having
filled these three only one way in which
the last slot can be filled as we are
filling the first and the second and the
third and the fourth slot we multiplied
these four numbers to get the answer 24
different ways in which the letters of
the word Rock can be arranged and this
is also for factorial you could have
written this answer directly provided
you've understood how we arrived at it
the number of arrangements or
permutations of n distinct objects is n
factorial indirectly this question asked
us for the number of anagrams of the
word Rock and this includes all the
meaningless ones as well like okay RC K
ROC and so on so this was easy now let
me ask you a similar question how many
different anagrams of MOOC can be formed
MOOC stands for massive open online
courses
how many anagrams like mo Co Co om can
be formed using the letters of MOOC try
it out and we will see the solution in
the next session
you